avec nous Pierre Olivier Pineau
professeur titulaire de la chair de
gestion du secteur de l'énergie à HEC
Montréal bonsoir est-ce que c'est une
réponse appropriée à l'administration
Biden que le plan vert qui a été
présenté hier bah oui en fait c'était
inévitable parce que beaucoup de gens
craignaient que les États-Unis attirent
l'essentiel des investissements en
énergie verte en électricité même si ou
le Canada est déjà une très gros
producteur d'énergie décarbonée 60% de
d'énergie renouvelable et 80% d'énergie
des carbonée quand on met le nucléaire
dans la balance donc malgré cela c'est
important étant donné les ambitions du
Canada d'avoir davantage énergie propre
de rivaliser avec les cadeaux fiscaux
américains et donc ce sont des cadeaux
fiscaux américains ce sont des crédits
d'impôts au Canada pour encourager la
production et la transmission mais pas
l'efficacité énergétique dont vous nous
parlez à chaque fois que vous nous
parlez oui et donc ça c'est qu'elle a un
aspect sur lequel le Canada n'a pas
suivi les États-Unis parce que dans le
il fashion Act américain il y avait une
bonne efficace des crédits pour la
rénovation d'homiciliaire de manière
importante et pour des raisons que qui
sont très troublantes le Canada n'a rien
fait là-dessus en termes d'efficacité
énergique pour les bâtiments alors que
nous sommes des plus gros consommateurs
d'énergie dans les résidences et d'une
manière générale au Canada que les
Américains il y a là des grands efforts
qu'on aurait pu accélérer et que on
repousse à plus tard quand même est-ce
que ça nous permet de nous rapprocher de
nos cibles d'émissions de réduction
d'émissions de gaz à effet de serre mais
ça va certainement promouvoir l'énergie
renouvelable dans la mesure cette
énergie renouvelable remplace des
énergies fossiles ce qui est pas
toujours le cas parce qu'on est très bon
dans nos sociétés à rajouter des qu'on
se des niveaux de consommation d'énergie
mais oui ça va quand même permettre de
remplacer du charbon et du gaz naturel
en électricité mais il faut faire
attention parce que si on ne fait
qu'ajouter sans retirer des usages et
bien on pourrait se retrouver avec
presque autant de d'émissions et pas de
réduction comme on vise parce qu'on ne
touche pas la consommation et c'est la
consommation vraiment que sur laquelle
il faudrait travailler bien plus
agressivement pour réduire les émissions
de gaz à effet de serre ou absolument le
ministre Girard s'est réjouit
aujourd'hui de ce crédit d'impôt
remboursable de 15 % sur l'électricité
propre on ne l'écoute
l'effort est important et puis ça va
aider c'est somme là pour la production
de l'hydroélectricité
l'électricité propre le fait qu'il est
au Québec est éligible très bon toute
notre filière batterie la transformation
de la fabrication les deux premiers
crédits d'impôts sont pertinents pour le
Québec vont être utiles c'est des bonnes
mesures
ça veut dire quoi pour une société comme
Hydro-Québec ma grosso modo c'est que
les projets coûtent 15% moins cher
puisque il y a un remboursement de 15%
du coût du projet et ça permet donc de
faire des projets à moindre coût pour
les Québécois ça va se traduire par des
des
approvisionnements qui coûtent moins
cher et probablement une hausse des
tarifs moindres parce que malgré tout
les nouveaux approvisionnements vont
quand même coûter plus cher que le coût
moyen de production d'aujourd'hui donc
mais au lieu de rajouter l'entièreté du
cours on en rajoutera un petit peu moins
parce que les générations futures vont
payer parce que il faut pas se leurrer
ces crédits d'impôts fédéraux c'est de
l'endettement que le gouvernement
fédéral
remet aux générations futures qui elles
devront payer pour les ajouts qu'on fait
aujourd'hui est-ce que c'est nouveau
est-ce que c'est une première dans votre
esprit à votre connaissance de voir le
gouvernement fédéral finalement financer
indirectement avec ses crédits d'impôts
des ouvrages
électriques provinciaux oui absolument
parce que l'énergie c'est vraiment d'une
compétence essentiellement provinciale
toutes les lignes de transport les
barrages ont toujours été payés par les
provinces et là le gouvernement veut
encourager de l'énergie plus propre
alors qu'on sait qu'il y a des provinces
dans lesquelles on tarde un petit peu on
a la difficulté à avancer donc c'est un
problème et surtout le gouvernement ça
c'est ça c'est à mon avis plus
significatif il veut qu'à voir plus de
lignes de transport entre les provinces
qui vont pouvoir bénéficier de ce crédit
d'impôt et ça ça va faciliter des
projets entre les provinces ce qui est
très important parce que on peut
équilibrer de la production éolienne
solaire hydroélectrique en ayant
davantage d'échanges quand il souffle
quand le vent souffle en Alberta c'est
pas vrai qu'ils sont forcément en
Saskatchewan et donc là ils pourront
échanger davantage et ça va être très
bien et quand vous parlez d'échanges
interprovisation vous passez aussi à la
boucle de l'Atlantique que le
gouvernement fédéral veut toujours voir
naître oui absolument dans les provinces
atlantiques Nouveau-Brunswick nouvelle
travaux 13 milliards en dépenses et le
système manque de fiabilité pour
l'instant absolument c'est un désastre à
la fois économique et de conception et
le Terre-Neuve et Labrador en souffrent
le gouvernement fédéral est venu à la
rescousse à plusieurs reprises ils ont
beaucoup financé ou donner des garanties
de prêt pour non seulement le projet
mais aussi une ligne de transport entre
le Labrador et la Nouvelle-Écosse
tout cet argent que le fédéral injecte
ça pourrait servir de levier pour
favoriser les négociations les plus
grandes collaboration mais personne
n'arrive à prendre de leadership nous
merci merci beaucoup ça me fait plaisir